[Music]
shag marry kill you ready yeah Shawn
Mendes Harry Styles Nick Jonas why oh my
god cuz that's not right it's brunch for
having fun there's mimosas I want to
know shag marry kill alright and Shawn
Mendes Harry Styles
are you gonna answer it - or is this
okay I will answer if you answer okay
Mary oh my god this is like so hard I
didn't know I was gonna answer this
either so now I'm like freaking out okay
[Music]
no okay okay can i I think I know Mary
Shawn Mendes shag Harry Styles kill Nick
Jonas that's not okay
since you answered I am gonna go Nick
deserves more than that and better than
that does which is why I'm gonna shag
him I'm gonna share Jonas I'm gonna
marry Oh God
I don't want the one Directioners to
come at me but I think I'm gonna marry
Shawn Mendes and kill Harry Styles ah
I'm sorry we just lived two different
lives
I just can't see ya alive and dad I
apologize I apologize
very fancy that's not a fair one no I
horrible I regret asking you cuz then I
had a response I would rather marry all
three but like a divorce but in whatever
order
[Music]
[Applause]